head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts one
thing I did want to uh ask you about was
your position on one of the big culture
War issues in this country is in Florida
they announced that that that that they
would be barring certain books from
curriculum that contained adult
materials this resulted in big headlines
like this about uh well this is not the
one uh Orlando newspaper publishes
spread of 673 Books banned in Florida
county in 2023 I was curious uh if you
knew a lot about what was going on
Nationwide with the removal of certain
books from school curriculum and what
your thoughts were I'm very much against
book Banning I think book Banning is is
is basically fascist Behavior some of
the books that are being banned there's
a uh there'll be a suggestion of
homosexual feelings so they call it so
so they call it pornographic and
something CH children shouldn't read I
trust uh teachers and Librarians and I
don't like the idea of the US government
or a state government telling Librarians
or teachers what they can teach you
don't you don't think there's you don't
think we should have laws on like what
about a Playboy like if a Playboy was in
a Grade School would that be an issue a
Playboy magazine yeah yeah as a parent
I'd have a big big problem with a
Playboy magazine what if what if there
was a book being given to middle
schoolers that depicted giving
I I yeah well okay once again
if yeah I wouldn't want my child to read
that and I definitely would be wanting
to work on this is the book okay that's
that school board that's not government
not the US government or or I don't want
the US government and I don't want the
state Governor telling me the books
cannot be uh taught if I were a parent
and my I am a parent if I if my child
and the eighth grade I would definitely
be going to the school I would
definitely be working with the school
board and I and I definitely would have
a problem with
that is it what if the school board if
it doesn't do anything about it then you
have to appeal to the state I don't want
the I don't want a governor telling uh
uh colleges what classes they can teach
this isn't colleges this is no and in
even school yeah no I don't think the
governor is to be telling schools what
they can teach in the eighth grade I
would have a problem with that but
that's school board and then you people
to your school board if you had a a
child between the ages of 10 and 12 and
the teacher was providing them
instruction on how to use anonymous gay
sex apps and would you call the police
on that on that teacher I would def I
would definitely go to the principal
right away police I have a problem with
bringing the police into that going to
the principal you better believe I would
and I would show up at the school board
as well so so the reason why I bring up
these these are very specific examples
uh this book is gay uh we have this
story from uh ABC parents call cops
after teacher offers this book is gay to
middle schoolers in Illinois this book
provides instruction on uh for the use
of uh gay dating apps for anonymous sex
and these are middle schoolers these are
these are 10 11 and 12 year olds so the
parents finding out that the teacher was
doing this I mean that's that's
pedophilia that's that's grooming
behavior that is outright egregious and
illegal when I I don't even want to say
conservatives but it seems to be the
case when uh let's say someone like me
I'm from Chicago and I grew up with a
Democrat family when I find out that
adults are providing children this kind
of stuff I say that's a bad thing we
shouldn't allow that however for some
reason I end up with uh we had the woman
um what was her name from the majority
report Emma vigland Emma vigland came on
and actually defended that these books
be kept in Middle Schools no I would not
agree with Emma vigin yeah I think she
hadn't read the books either when she
made that statement could so this is the
this is the culture War isue and the
reason why I bring it up is I often find
that people who would align themselves
as more Democrat or left leaning are not
familiar with the books in question that
are being challenged by parents and so
you end up with these stories that are
not correct they'll say something like
you know oh To Kill a Mocking Bird and
it's like
I I'm not I'm not concerned at all about
ideas and philosophy you know I think
critical race Theory as a philosophy it
can be taught in schools but as uh as
practice I don't think that's
appropriate so the criticism became with
Florida it it's not that they had books
on critical race Theory it's that they
had critical race practice in books
which what are you calling critical race
practice practice so uh for instance
there is a uh what was one example we
had
um I forgot the woman's name uh was it
asra noani yeah that was her name one of
the a lot of the books that they were
bringing into Florida would say
something like you know we have the
classic math problem where it says a
train leaves Cincinnati traveling 50 m
an hour and a train departs Pittsburgh
traveling at whatever and you know at
what point do they pass but now what the
books are doing it'll say Evan is white
and has been detained by police two
times in the past year Jamal is black
and has been detained 17 times what
percentage of the times have police been
racist and these are the kinds of
questions that are being put in books so
in so this is called Praxis where the
idea of the ideology is embedded in a
separate subject parents were upset
saying hey this is IDE ological and not
relevant to the subject of science or
math we don't want this as part of the
curriculum too soon and so then what
ended up happening is they say okay well
we're going to remove this from
curriculum but then of course the media
reports it as Republicans banned books
but well but see even the way we're
contextualizing the conversation I don't
think is very helpful I don't think it's
a left right issue for instance if you
are a parent and you don't want your
child in the seventh grade reading a
book about I mean that's just
to me that's not a left right issue that
the is learning about that in school but
to me as an American not as a left
Winger but as an American I do want my
child to learn for instance about
unequal application of Criminal Justice
uh when it comes to race if a black
person is uh given a sentence in a in a
in a uh courtroom in the United States
it that black person is liable to have a
20% longer sentence what I didn't like
about what you said was it was a
specific projection projection onto the
police when not every policeman is
racist that's practice however yeah the
idea though that the white person is
stopped so much less than the black
person I don't have a problem with kids
learning that in high school but
shouldn't those shouldn't topics like
that be their own subject as opposed to
mixed into other topics because what end
up H what ends up happening is if you're
teaching kids math and you're
adding additional subcontext then that's
then you end up with with people that
aren't learning the subject they're
supposed to be learning and that's part
of why our our our schools have such a
problem with with making uh making test
scores and have we have kids that are
graduating without you know that can't
read at grade level some can't read
functionally can't read at all and a lot
of it is because of these kind of this
means of teaching this for the for the
type of the type of teaching and the
framework they use it's it's part of the
re I mean there's a lot of reasons
there's there's there's parents aren't
aren't making sure their kids are
getting to school and stuff parents
aren't you aren't taking care of of
their parental duties there's a lot of
things opioids there's yeah kids
dropping out and stuff like that
absolutely there's a lot of reasons but
you are you do see the more a whatever
institution whatever you're dealing with
whether it be an institution or whether
it be corporations with their HR
departments focusing on on like Dei and
stuff like that when you have when you
have those type of departments and that
kind of focus you are taking away some
of the at least a portion of the
resources that are supposed to go to
actually teaching and you're putting
them to things that don't teach them or
or hinder the them teaching because if
that were its own class in like whether
it be social studies or whatever in
civics or whatever um if the the the
type of of you know awareness or social
justice was was its own class that's one
thing but if you're mixing it in with
other things then you're going to have
have it watered you have a problem with
uh this sorry s you're making some some
some points that are understandable
however the what those of us on the left
are are arguing that children should
learn for instance our racial history in
this country well no one's arguing
against that yes many people are arguing
against that I'm sorry many people are
arguing against that and there's this
hysteria about critical race Theory and
they think just teaching people about
the history of slavery in the United
States
that's do you know that there are
schools there are schools I remember I
was in South Carolina and there's a law
that if any any child goes um to the
teacher and says that made me
uncomforable fortable that then the
teacher cannot teach that book yeah and
that came from the left because of
people that like from from
microaggressions and stuff like that if
you feel uncomfortable in a in a class
it was it was the left leaning people
that wanted I kind of agree with that
actually yeah the left leing people were
like oh as a child all that that has to
happen in that case is that the parents
tell the child tell tell the teacher
this makes you uncomfortable once a
child gets into High School you start
reading books about things that I mean
part of literature part of Art part of
movies there are some things that are
going to make you uncomfortable and if
you really know unit States let let let
me do you agree with critical race
Theory critical race theory was just
something that had to it's so
misunderstood it was something that had
to do with a legal theory that people
were talking about in like law school um
but there are things that have to are
you not familiar with the the ideology
of critical race Theory it has to do
with the idea that many things are seen
through and filtered through the the um
through the lens of of race but many
things that that parents have been
lining up to complain about in um in in
school boards around the country just
were anything that had to do with race
and calling it in in this almost
hysteria about critical race Theory I
think there's a big difference between
critical race Theory and teaching
children the truth about the history of
the United States which I believe
regardless of our politics is a is a
requirement for conscious citizenship so
outside of perhaps are a lot of ignorant
people who aren't they're complaining
for a variety of reasons I won't speak
to them I'm sure they exist the
political stances taken by uh many
people uh that were fighting books on
critical race theory was what's called
critical race practice and that is to
take the ideology from Kimberly krenshaw
and Derrik Bell and apply it into
schools through science and math and
other subjects unrelated to say social
studies so you you'd end up with a lot
of uh uh political commentators saying
saying things like uh my position for
instance take the literal book critical
race Theory and bring it to any school
you want and let children read it and
even give them a lesson on it but
critical race practice was when they did
like a math problem like you were just
talking about right yeah so the the
issue I take with critical race theory
is that it is an abhorent racist
ideology that uh advocates for
segregation and the critical race
practice was to take that ideology and
apply it and teach children thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net